although much of the canon information
about the mandalorian jedi war is still
up in the air here's what we know so far
this is the history of the mandalorian
jedi war explained
as odd as it sounds the war started
because the mandalorians did not
understand the jedi when they first
encountered them
even at the end of the mandalorian
season 1 the armorer describes the jedi
as
an order of sorcerers due to this lack
of understanding the mandalorians
created weapons and armor
to better combat these mysterious new
opponents in 2017 comicbook.com
interviewed dave filoni about how the
star wars rebels episode
trials of the darksaber referenced the
mandalorian jedi war
he explained the mandalorian jedi war
that i have in my mind
is very much derived from the oldest
style of thinking of mandalorians
which was that their weapons their
arsenal their technology
had a massive increase once they
collided with the jedi
and found these force-wielding people
that had abilities they
didn't understand more and more
animosity occurred between the
mandalorians and jedi
once the latter group started
interfering with the former's crusades
the 2016 reference book star wars aliens
of the galaxy
details how a group of sword-wielding
mandalorians
known as the mandalorian crusaders
carried out a series of conquests
across the galaxy while in the inner rim
the crusaders devastated a planet called
abdurya out of contempt for the native
obdurians
who they viewed as dishonorable cowards
the mandalorian crusaders also fought
the jedi at some point during these
missions
murals of the mandalorian crusaders
fighting the jedi
were created and can be seen in a few
episodes of star wars the clone wars
as well as one episode of star wars
rebels
even though mandalorians and jedi were
at one point sworn
enemies a member of the former group did
create a lightsaber of his own
that member was tar vizla the first
mandalorian
ever inducted into the jedi order tara
created a unique
black colored lightsaber called the
darksaber during his time as a jedi
after he died the jedi kept the saber in
the jedi temple
but during the fall of the old republic
members of house vizsla
raided that temple and reclaimed the
sabre they used it to unite their people
and defeat anyone who opposed them
including jedi the darksaber would
become a symbol of power to the
mandalorians
and was used to unite them before and
after the mandalorian jedi war
the mandalorian jedi war became so
heated that near the end of their wars
the mandalorians turned concordia the
moon of their homeworld
into a mining base although the
mandalorians put up a good fight against
the jedi
it was not enough to save their
homeworld the mandalorian jedi war
ended with a final battle which caused a
cataclysm that scorched
much of mandalore into a white
uninhabitable wasteland
the jedi won the war but not all was
lost for the mandalorians as they
created hermetically sealed domed cities
on mandalore's surface
years after the mandalorian jedi war
ended many mandalorians
including satin crees did not want to
continue the cycle of violence that
almost destroyed their planet
they formed a peaceful movement called
the new mandalorians
42 years before the battle of yavin a
civil war broke out between the new
mandalorians
and the martial traditionalists who both
sought control for mandalore
the death toll during this war was a
primary reason why sateen became a
pacifist for the rest of her life
as duchess satine rebuilt mandalore and
it
thrived under her leadership for 20
years
mandalore went on to become an active
participant in the senate of the
galactic republic while still remaining
neutral throughout the majority of the
clone wars
of course many mandalorians still
opposed the new mandalorians pacifist
ideals and
wanted to return mandalore to its
warrior ways
these same mandalorians would go on to
form the terrorist organization
deathwatch under the leadership of
governor prix vizsla and sateen's sister
bocaton crees
deathwatch was initially aligned with
count dooku and the separatists
but they parted ways and eventually
joined forces with a renegade sith lord
named maul to take over mandalore
together maul
and vizsla devised a plan to make the
new mandalorians look
weak in order to gain the people's trust
death watch is here to save you from
these intergalactic gangsters that
threaten our great city
the plan was successfully carried out
and vizsla declared himself
ruler of mandalore but he betrayed maul
and imprisoned him
it didn't take long for maul to escape
which allowed maul to challenge vizsla
to a duel which he won
after beheading vizsla with the
darksaber maul declared himself the new
leader of death watch and installed a
puppet prime minister
while he ruled from the shadows after
becoming ruler of mandalore
maul retained the loyalty of most of the
members of death watch
but some members such as bo katan could
not accept the idea of an outsider
ruling mandalore
and led a resistance against him in the
seventh season of the clone wars
maul's reign is cut short after former
jedi knight ahsoka tano and bocaton
team up to launch a full-scale assault
in an attempt to liberate mandalore from
the clutches of the shadow collective
before ordering the other shadow
collective leaders to go into hiding
maul is captured but subsequently
escapes custody in the wake of order 66
the 2018 spin-off film solo a star wars
story
set after the events of the clone wars
season seven
reveals that maul established another
crime syndicate
called the crimson dawn even though
bogatan and her forces defeated maul and
freed mandalore from the shadow
collective
it didn't take long for the empire to
undo all that progress
after bogota refuses to comply with the
imperial occupation of her homeworld
clan saxon betrayed her and swore
allegiance to emperor palpatine
fortunately bo katan joined forces with
clan wren the mandalorian protectors
and members of the rebel alliance to
fight back against clan saxon
following this victory bocaton was given
the darksaber and took up the title of
manned allure
a title assumed by the sole leader of
the mandalorian people
unfortunately the empire would strike
back against the remaining mandalorians
in the form of the great
purge this event saw the deaths of many
mandalorians across the galaxy
and the empire stealing massive amounts
of vesgar
a metal alloy that mandalorians use to
create their
signature armor in the season one finale
of the mandalorian the tribe's armorer
tells dinjaran that he needs to reunite
the child with his people that mission
sends bando on a series of adventures
including one that puts him in direct
contact with bogatan and her fellow
mandalorian separatists
although they don't share jaron's rigid
adherence to the mandalorian creed
bokuton
ultimately helps him on his mission in
exchange for his help in raiding an
imperial ship
mando is initially led to believe the
separatists are simply trying to steal
weapons from the shattered empire but
it eventually becomes clear that boca
ton is really after the dark saber
now wielded by moff gideon living up to
her end of the deal
she also tells jaren where to find a
jedi telling him to seek out ahsoka tano
mando heads to the planet corvus a
deforested wasteland where sokatano has
been waging a war against the brutal
reign of a figure known as the
magistrate
upon mando's arrival he's shepherded to
an audience with the magistrate who
offers him a staff
made of pure baskar in exchange for
murdering
ahsoka instead he joins forces with
ahsoka
following a brief skirmish when they
meet in the corvus wastelands
mando offers to help ahsoka defeat the
magistrate in exchange for her accepting
and training the child
as expected the magistrate is no match
for the duo but
ahsoka is unable to live up to her end
of the deal
telling mando that she can't train the
child she's able to speak with him via
the force
and learns that his real name is grogu
and that he was trained on coruscant
before being taken during the fall of
the jedi
but she also discovers a great deal of
fear anger and
darkness in him and having been close to
anakin skywalker
she's all too aware of how those
feelings can be exploited
although ahsoka is unable or unwilling
to train grogu
she offers manda one other way to
fulfill his obligation
take him to the planet tython where
grogu may be able to tap into the force
at the site of some ancient temple ruins
and establish a connection with another
jedi
in the middle of that process however
grogu is kidnapped by moff gideon's
forces
mando gathers the crew to overtake
gideon's leg cruiser
and save the child after reaching
groku's cell mando battles gideon
ultimately mando disarms gideon with the
best guard spear he received from ahsoka
back on corvus after taking grogu and a
shackled gideon to the bridge
mando offers the darksaber to bogatan
but she refuses
gideon clarifies that the darksaber
cannot be given
and must be won in combat their standoff
is interrupted when a jedi
luke skywalker himself arrives to rescue
them from a squad of dark troopers
and take grogo away to be trained will
mando and grogu's connection last
or will the events of the mandalorian
jedi war repeat themselves once again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite star wars histories are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]